[Music]
welcome dear listeners to a crucial
episode of empathy Unleashed I'm your
host dinina and today we confront a
pressing concern bullying in our
educational institutions our aim is to
delve deep into the incases of this
issue exploring its roots the
far-reaching
consequences and most importantly the
strategies to eradicate it bullying a
blight that tarnishes the sensity of our
schools has roots that Snak through
various aspects of society a dark cloud
over our schools has roots interent with
various societal elements from a lack of
empathy to socioeconomic disparities the
causes of bullying are Asal facted as
they are deeply
ingrained bullying in schools can arise
from various complex factors often
rooted in social dynamics and individual
experiences one significant cause is a
lack of empathy and understanding where
some students struggle to recognize the
feelings and perspective of others
additionally issues related to power
ambulance such as differences in
physical appearance academic abilities
or social status can trigger bullying
Behavior as some individuals seek to
assert control over others insecurity
and low self-esteem in bullies can drive
them to Target others attempting to
boost their self-worth through negative
means home environments and family
Dynamics also play a role children who
experience aggression neglect or in
consistent discipline at home May
replicate those behaviors in school
settings moreover exposure to violence
in media and online platforms can
desensitize
individuals influencing their attitudes
and actions towards peers addressing
these underlying causes requires a
holistic approach involving education
awareness and fostering a posi positive
empathetic atmosphere both at home and
in
schools bullying in schools has
far-reaching
consequences that can profoundly impact
the lives of both the victim and the
preparators for the victims the effect
often extend beyond the school years
leading to emotional distress low
self-esteem anxiety and
depression being constantly subjected to
harassment and humiliation can hinder
academic performance and result in
school avoidance further hindering their
educational progress social isolation is
common as beled individuals may find it
challenging to trust others or form
healthy
relationships in extreme cases victims
May resort to self harm or even
contemplate suicide feeling trapped and
helpless on the other hand preparators
of bullying also face serious
repercussions their behavior if left
unaddressed can escalate leading to
disciplinary actions legal consequences
and a higher likehood of engaging in
criminal activities later in
life moreover witnessing or being aware
aware of
bullying incidents can create a toxic
atmosphere within the school Community
affecting the overall learning
environment thus the consequences of
bullying amplifies the Urgent needs to
proactive measures to prevent and
address this issue promoting empathy
understanding and a culture of respect
in
schools now let's shift our Focus to
strategies that can comb back dis meance
that can dismantle the walls of bullying
in our schools education both at home
and in schools is a Paramount parents
and Educators must instill values of
empathy tolerance and respect in the
younger generation as a saying goes
prevention is better than cure creating
awareness campaigns implementing
mentorship programs and fostering an
inclusive School culture are proven
strategies advocated by organiz
izations preventing bullying in schools
necessitates a comprehensive approach
involving students teachers parents and
the Border Community Schools should
prioritize creating a safe and exclusive
environment where every students feels
valued and respected implementing
evidencebased anti building programs
that emphasize empathy conflict
resolutions and communic ation skills
can Empower students to understand the
impact of their actions and Foster
positive relationships teachers and
staff members should receive training to
recognize signs of bullying and
intervene effectively encouraging a
culture of kindness and acceptance
through a classroom discussions
awareness campaigns and extracurricular
activities can reinforce positive
behavior schools should also establish
clear policies against bullying ensuring
consistent enforcement and consequences
for the preparators engaging parents by
educating them about bullying prevention
strategies and encouraging their
supportive community that values respect
and
empathy schools can create an
environment where bullying is not
tolerated and every student can serve
academically and
emotionally certainly preventing
bullying in schools is a complex
challenge that necessitates a
compressive sustained effort from all
stakeholders involved a pivotal aspect
for this approach is fostering a
positive School climate where mutual
respect tolerance and acceptance are not
just encouraged but ingrained into the
very fabric of the school Community
Schools can promote empathy and
understanding the curriculum and Chas Ms
integrating lessons on diversity
inclusion and acceptance into various
subjects these lessons can help students
appreciate differences and cultivate
compression for others making it harder
for bullying Behavior to take
roote in addition to curriculum changes
and classroom strategies utilizing
technology in a positive manner can be
powerful schools and arn social media
and other digital platforms to spread a
war about the impact of bullying and
share stories of kindness and resilience
creating online spaces where students
can engage in constructive discussions
about bullying and its preventions can
faciliate the sense of community and
empowerment enabling them to stand up
against bullying
collectively furthermore involving the
Border Community is essential Community
leaders local organizations and law
enforcement agencies can collaborate
with schools to organize awareness
campaigns workshops and seminars these
events can educate parents students and
community members about the signs of
bullying its various forms and effective
prevention strategies by fostering a
sense of collective responsibility the
community becomes a proactive Force
against
bullying regular and open communication
between schools and parents is the key
parents should be aware of the school's
anti-bullying policies procedures for
reporting incidents and the support
available for their children schools can
organize parents teachers meetings
specifically focused on bullying
prevention ensuring that parents are
active parents in the creating a safe
learning environment by fostering a
strong partnership between home and
school a consistent message against
bullying is reinforced both in and out
of the school
premises in conclusion preventing
building in schools Demands a holistic
collaborative and sustained effort it
requires changes in the curriculum
classroom practices and school policies
coupled with the active involvement of
teachers parents students and the
community by addressing this issue
compressively and promoting a culture of
empathy respect and kindness schools can
create an environment where bullying is
not tolerated and various students feel
safe valued and
supported involving parents is a
Paramount schools can organize seminars
and training sessions for parents
offering guidance on how to identify
signs that their child might be a victim
or preparator of bullying open lines of
communication between parents and School
staff should be
encouraged ensuring that concerns are
addressed promptly collaboration with
Community organizations such as mental
health services local law enforcement
and nonprofit dedicated to anti-bullying
efforts can amplify the impact of
prevent prevention programs these
partnership can offer additional
resources conselling services and
expertise enriching the support network
available to schools thank you so much
for joining us on the episode of Bing in
schools it's been an incredible journey
and we're so glad you came along for the
ride until next time take
[Music]
care
a